pendant la seconde guerre mondiale alors
que des centaines de millions de soldats
combattent au front dans les océans et
dans les airs un jeune mathématicien est
embauché par les services secrets
anglais
sa mission casser les codes utilisés par
les forces nazies pour communiquer de
manière chiffrée cette mission
paraissait impossible désespéré et sans
espoir
après tout les nazis avaient choisi un
chiffrement fondée sur une machine à
pets enigma dont le nombre de
configurations se comptaient en trias ou
plus précisément autour de 10 puissance
dans voilà un nombre plus castro nomique
il s'agit d'un nombre cryptographiques
le jeune homme un certain alan turing
n'était pas n'importe quel mathématicien
il était l'un des plus grands
mathématiciens de l'histoire mais son
génie allait faire basculer l'histoire
en donnant un avantage stratégique aux
forces alliées selon certains historiens
c'est mathématique aurait ainsi permis
de raccourcir la guerre de plusieurs
années ce qui correspond à sauver des
millions de vies certains affirment même
que l'issue de la guerre aurait pu être
différente sans les calculs salvateur de
turing et de ses collègues
alors il faudrait des heures et des
heures de vidéo pour expliquer les
mathématiques déployés par turing pour
craquer les codes nazis donc clairement
je vais pouvoir qu'effleurer certaines
astuces de turing en fait je ne veux
inciter que sur une astuce crucial
développé par turing à savoir
l'introduction de l'échelle
logarithmique des rapports de crédence
aussi appelé peine debout et smooth que
je vais plus simplement appelée le
curseur de turing
mais avant de parler du curseur de
turing il faut que je vous parle un peu
plus des codes nazis pour chiffrer un
message les nazis utiliser une machine
appelée enigma enigma avait des réglages
à base de câbles et à base de rotor pour
déchiffrer un code nazis il fallait
deviner le positionnement des câbles et
les positions des rotors une propriété
importante des rotors c'est qu'à chaque
fois qu'une lettre était tapé sur la
machine
la position des rotors avancer d'un cran
on obtenait alors un autre réglage
d'enigma et ça ça veut dire que si deux
messages sont chiffrés avec les mêmes
positions des câbles alors il existe un
nombre de frappes du premier message
après lequel la configuration du rotor
d'enigma sera la même
qu'au moment de commencer le chiffrage
du second message l'une des astuces
importante du déchiffrage des codes des
nazis port turing était justement de
trouver le nombre de frappes du premier
message au bout duquel les rotors
d'enigma des deux messages étaient dans
les mêmes configurations et ça c'est un
premier pas critique car grâce à cela on
disposera alors de deux messages et même
potentiellement de nombreux messages
chiffrés avec la même configuration
d'enigma ce qui permettra de mieux
tester la plausibilité de différentes
configurations des câbles ok mais
comment savoir si deux morceaux de
messages chiffrés sur le résultat d'une
même configuration des limes n'hésitez
pas à mettre pause pour réfléchir une
minute c'est quelque chose qui peut être
trouvée allez je vous laisse encore 5
secondes pour m oppose l'astuce pour
deviner cela c'est de constater que les
messages originaux des nazis étaient
écrits en allemand et qu'en allemand
certaines aides sont plus fréquentes que
d'autres en particulier dans les phrases
en allemand
environ 16% des lettres sont des oeufs
qui d'ailleurs est légèrement plus qu'en
français et j'ai été surpris de
découvrir que la deuxième est la plus
fréquente en allemand est la lettre n 30
à paris gallargues et en particulier
toutes les lettres en allemand ne sont
pas et qu probable et du coup si on
prend deux phrases en allemand alors il
arrivera un peu plus souvent que le
hasard que des oeufs ou des haines
coïncide au même rang du mot on a
légèrement plus souvent des coïncidences
de lettres que si on prenait des
messages complètement aléatoire et de
façon cruciale si maintenant deux
morceaux de messages sont chiffrés avec
la même configuration d'enigma alors
toute coïncidence dans les messages
originaux correspondra à une coïncidence
dans les messages chiffrés en fait on
peut aller plus loin que ça ait remarqué
que certaines combinaisons de lettres
sont particulièrement fréquentes
par exemple d eux est particulièrement
fréquent notamment à cause des pronoms
comme des herbes den ouden mieux encore
il existe des mots qui sont très
récurrents comme le mot ein du coup les
successions de coïncidences sont
particulièrement révélatrice d'un
chiffrage commun noté que j'utilise ici
le mot coïncidence sens littéral à
savoir incidence simultanées oui parce
que la grande question qu'on peut se
poser c'est si une coïncidence dans des
messages chiffrés est vraiment une
coïncidence
autrement dit est-ce dû au hasard ou
serait ce parce que les mots
sont chiffrés avec la même configuration
d'enigma et bien intuitivement chaque
coïncidence dans des messages chiffrés
devraient augmenter notre crédence en le
fait que ces messages ont été chiffrées
avec la même configuration d'enigma et
chaque nom coïncidence devrait
légèrement diminuer cette crédence vous
sentez venir la formule de maïs alors
avant d'en venir au match je vais
rapidement vous parler de comment turing
et ses collègues faisait pour compter
les nombre de coïncidences temps des
messages chiffrés ce qu'ils faisaient
sait faire imprimer dans une ville
appelée bonne boury des feuilles de
papier avec des lettres en colonne puis
un message été encodée sur une feuille
papier en faisant des trous dans les
colonnes correspondante
par exemple si la première lettre du
misaal chiffré est un cas alors abane
bourrique les employés faisait un trou
dans la première colonne hauteur du cac
et ainsi de suite avec la deuxième
lettre la troisième lettre et le reste
du message chiffré
puis il prenait deux messages
prêt ainsi encoder et pour savoir
comment décaler les deux messages il
faisait glisser la deuxième feuille sur
la première pour chaque glissement il
éclairait les deux feuilles et comptait
ensuite le nombre de spots lumineux
ainsi obtenu est donc intuitivement
beaucoup de spots lumineux suggéré qu'il
s'agissait du bon glissement c'est à
dire d'un glissement qui fait que l'être
chiffrés ont été obtenus avec le même
réglages d'enigma ok mais comment
déterminer si le nombre de coïncidences
observé suffit à considérer qu'un
glissement donné correspond vraiment un
chiffrement des messages avec la même
configuration d'enigma et bien c'est là
qu'intervient la formule 2 bis ou
presque le problème de la forme de bèze
et qu'elle est difficile à calculer et
le génie de turing fut de trouver une
manière de contourner son calcul pour
cela au lieu de s'intéresser à la
crédence qu'un glissement correspond à
un chiffrement parler même configuration
de la machine
turing se concentra sur le rapport de
crédence entre la théorie bon glissement
et la théorie mauvais glissement ce
genre de rapports de crédence est aussi
appelée cote ou aux anglais c'est
typiquement ce genre de corte qui est
utilisé par les bookmakers et les paris
sportifs par exemple une cote de 2
contre 7 signifie que si je perds le
pari je perds 2 et si je gagne le pari
je gagne 7 ou de façon équivalente dans
un pari à 2 contre 7 je mets deux sur la
table
mon adversaire mais cette et le
vainqueur récupère tout la mise voilà un
pareil que j'aurais intérêt à prendre si
ma crédence en gagner / mac rae dansant
perdre est supérieure ou égale à 2 7e ou
dit de façon équivalente est peut-être
plus compréhensible une cote de 2 contre
7 est exactement ce que je proposerai
simon rapport de crédence est égal à 2
7e
je vous invite à démontrer que ceux ci
il revient dire que mc rae dansant
gagner et d'égal à 2 / 2 plus est kate
égale à 2 9e
ok mais quel est l'intérêt de ces cotes
et bien les codes simplifie grandement
le calcul bayésiens en effet quand on
applique la formule 2 bis pour les cotes
a posteriori on voit que les horribles
fonction de partitions s'annulent si
bien qu'il nous reste simplement deux
termes
commençons par le second terme il s'agit
des cotes a priori comme toujours dans
le boys and his mme cet a priori est
fondamental et il est souvent utile de
voir la forme de bèze commune
mise à jour de cette cote a priori via
l'analyse de nouvelles données en
pratique dans le cas des mi'kmaq grâce à
des informations spécifiques qui serait
un peu longues à expliquer ici
turing et ses collègues est arrivé
souvent identifié des messages dont il
était sûr qu'un glissement entre 25 vers
la gauche et 25 vers la droite
correspondait au chiffrage des messages
par la même configuration d'enigma du
coup a priori on a cinquante glissement
possible donc la crédence a priori d'un
glissement est égal à 1 50e ce qui
correspond à une cote à priori 2 1
contre 49
on peut passer aux premiers terre de
notre équation celui ci est parfois
appelé le rapport de vraisemblance où le
facteur de bêtises mais je préfère
l'appeler le rapport de surprises pour
insister sur le fait qu'il a à voir avec
à quel point les données sont
surprenantes plus précisément il décrit
à quel point la donne est observé et
davantage surprenante si on suppose le
glissement mauvais par opposition à six
ans suppose le glissement bon intuitive
en plus ce rapport de surprise est grand
plus la théorie bon glissement devrait
voler de la crédence à la théorie
alternative mauvais glissement en effet
ça ça correspond à dire que la première
théorie explique bien mieux les données
que la seconde elle rend les données
moins surprenante turine calcul a que
pour une coïncidence isolé le rapport de
surprise est environ égal à 25 17e
autrement dit on est 25 17e fois moins
surpris par une coïncidence si le
glissement est supposé bompard position
assise les supposés de mauvais
al'inverse l'absence de coïncidences
correspond un rapport de surprises
d'environ 416 / 425 et si on a des
coïncidences successives alors le
rapport de surprise est bien plus grand
encore que 25 17e pour calculer les
cotes a posteriori d'un certain
glissement il suffit alors de partir
décote a priori puis de multiplier
celle-ci par les rapports de surprises
pour les coïncidences et absence de
coïncidence si les cotes a posteriori
devient ainsi supérieur à 1
c'est que le glissement et plus
probablement bon que mauvais il reste
toutefois un problème pour appliquer la
formule de bsb code turing devait alors
se taper des calculs de multiplication
or faire une multiplication ça reste une
opération assez difficile même si on a
tous appris ce qu'était la
multiplication il nous est généralement
plus facile de raisonner sur une échelle
additive pour transformer la
multiplication en addition turing
modifié à l'échelle multiplicatif décote
en une et ciel additive des logarithme
décote à l'aide de l'opérateur
mathématique appelé le logarithme bon le
logarithme et c'est en fait un peu
compliqué d'expliquer ce que c'est je
vous renvoie vers ses excellentes vidéos
de mickael launay qui les expliquent
très bien et je vais un peu caché tout
ça sous le tapis pour aujourd'hui
quoi qu'il en soit on obtient une
échelle a dit yves décote qu'on appelle
aussi les log cote et que je vais
appeler plutôt le curseur de turing pour
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
il s'agit d'une échelle qui va de moins
l'infini à + l'infini avec à chaque
goutte une théorie par exemple ici tout
à droite et la théorie bondissement
tandis que tout à gauche on à la théorie
mauvais glissement est quelque part sur
cette droite de turing en place un
curseur qui décline au cot entre les
deux théories si ce curseur est au
milieu c'est que les deux théories
semble et puis probable s'il est à
gauche c'est que la théorie mauvais
glissement est plus probable et plus il
est à droite plus c'est la théorie bon
glissement qui est davantage probable
que la théorie mauvais glissement tu
auras un peu plus précis que ceux là
encore puisqu'il réussit à graduer cette
droite
alors il se trouve que turing a gradué
cette droite avec l'échelle de ce qu'il
a appelé les penrith mousse qui
correspond à utiliser un logarithme
décote en base 10 un peu comme ces faits
pour les bh où les décibels mais je vous
propose dans cette série de faire un peu
nos informaticiens et d'utiliser le
logarithme on passe deux qui me semble
plus facile à interpréter dans ce cas
l'unité qui graduent la droite de turing
est le bit qui est proportionnelle au
ban boris mousse puisque humble boris
mois c'est environ 3 32 bits ainsi si le
curseur est un beat à droite du milieu
c'est que la théorie à droite ici bon
glissement est deux fois plus probable
que la théorie à gauche si les trois
bits
à gauche la théorie mauvais glissement
devient deux puissances 3 et qui est
égale à 8 soit plus crédible que la
théorie combi cement a priori on a vu
que la théorie mauvais glissement
étaient 49 fois plus crédible que la
théorie bon glissement ça veut dire que
le curseur est initialement à log en
baisse de 2,49
soit environ 5 61 bits du côté mauvais
glissement maintenant pour chaque
nouvelle lettre analysée
on peut calculer exactement comment
déplacer ce curseur ce déplacement sera
le logarithme base d'oeufs durs rapport
de surprise dont on a parlé plus tôt à
chaque coïncidence unique
ce déplacement sera de log en base de 2
25 17e soit un peu plus d'un demi bits
vers la droite
chaque nom coïncidence déplacera le
curseur de log en base de 2 425 417e
soit 0,03 bits vers la gauche et des
coïncidences multiples correspondront à
des déplacements relativement importants
supérieurs aux beats vers la droite
les valeurs des déplacements en fonction
de la longueur de la suite de
coïncidences ont été calculés par turing
on parle de big g de tri g de
tétragramme et ainsi de suite
et elles ont vraiment été crucial pour
calculer adéquatement les codes a
posteriori en particulier ce qui est
désormais génial c'est que turing et ses
collègues pouvaient aisément mettre à
jour leur crédence sans appliquer la
complexe formule de pays à l'aide de
corte et de logarithmes turing avait
réussi à ramener l'apprentissage à de
simples déplacements additifs qu'un
curseur sur une droite graduée
relativement simple à interpréter et ça
s'applique à toutes sortes de problèmes
quand il ya deux théories alternatives
en jeu que vous souhaitez comparer il
semble que la meilleure façon
d'effectuer les calculs bayésiens en
pratique soin d'exploiter cette droite
de turing en commençant par placer le
curseur de la turing sur cette droite
conformément à votre préjugés bayésiens
puis en déplaçant adéquatement ce
curseur à gauche ou à droite pour chaque
nouvelle donnée en fonction du rapport
de surprises je vous invite un peu à
méditer tout cela si vous êtes un peu
perdu rassurez vous on verra la semaine
prochaine
comment s'appuyer sur le curseur de
turing dans d'autres cas plus simple
dernière fois j'avais pris pas mal de
citations de statisticiens très récent
de mars 2010neuf qui parlait des
problèmes autour notamment de la paix va
lui est également d'autres problèmes dus
sur l'utilisation des statistiques en
général par les scientifiques
et ça a fait réagir argot rate qui fait
remarquer que beaucoup des points
abordés dans la vidéo précédente
correspond à des instructions sur ce
qu'il ne faut pas faire
et du coup on peut se demander du coup
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire et ça c'est
un point qui est vraiment vraiment
abordé par notamment l'éditorial de
diamagueune satisfaction qui commence
par ce qu'il ne faut pas faire mais qui
a ensuite de longues discussions sur ce
qu'il faut faire parce qu'eux aussi se
sont bien rendu compte que bien souvent
les sept ici en dise est davantage ce
qu'il ne fallait pas faire que ce qu'il
fallait faire et ce qui est intéressant
avec cet éditorial celle qui compile un
petit peu tous les articles qui ont eu
qui ont été publiées par différents
statisticiens donc les saillies une
certaine manière de regrouper un petit
peu les avis de tous les statisticiens
et c'est difficile comme on l'avait eu
car il ya quand même beaucoup beaucoup
de désaccords entre statisticiens et
malgré tout ces désaccords il ya
certains points qui semblent vraiment
consensuelle et parmi tous ces points il
y en a qui sont vraiment vraiment
consensuelle et c sont ceux qui ont été
mises en avant par cet éditorial donc le
premier sur lequel insiste l'éditorial
si le fait d'accepter l'incertitude et
c'est peut-être finalement l'un des plus
importants peut-être le plus important
de cet éditorial c'est que il faut
s'habituer à raisonner avec
d'incertitude il faut embrasser la
certitude parce que le monde est
compliqué et il faut l'accepter et il
faut également accepter que l'on à un
ensemble fini de données et des
capacités cognitives très limité et que
étant donné tout cela il faut
reconnaître le fait que le plupart du
temps on sera dans l'incertitude et il
faut du coup accepté cette incertitude
est raisonnée avec cette incertitude
donc prendre la décision
avec l'incertitude je pense vraiment que
c'est le point le plus important de cet
éditorial
c'est vraiment accepter enfin qu' on est
dans des situations d'incertitude et il
faut absolument raisonner avec
l'incertitude tout le temps c'est pour
ça que tout ce qui est un peu conclusion
sans degré d'incertitude me semble
extrêmement problématique
c'est en particulier le cas de la phrase
statistiquement significatifs il existe
un effet statistique significative
ça semble rejeter
une incertitude qui devrait avoir et
qu'il faudrait en fait avoir vis-à-vis
de telle ou tel problème
un point sur lequel il est très
important d'insister également c'est le
fait que cette incertitude c'est pas
juste je sais pas c'est pas non plus 50
% oui ou non c'est souvent une
incertitude que l'on peut décrire
beaucoup beaucoup plus finement et il
faut prendre le temps de réfléchir à
comment décrire cette incertitude de la
meilleure manière et c'est vraiment un
travail important à faire qui est
difficile mais qui est sans doute la
partie la plus importante de la
réflexion de façon très générale
en tout cas c'est toute la raison d'être
de cette série et du parisianisme
vraiment le bail cynisme c'est avant
tout raisonner avec l'incertitude
raisonner en présence d' incertitudes et
ça c'est en fait plus ou moins le
deuxième point de cette tribune le fait
qu'il faille réfléchir on a tendance à
penser qu' il faut faire l'expérience et
l'expérience permettra de trancher et on
n'aura plus besoin de réfléchir parce
que l'expérience ne leur a dit ce qu'il
faut penser en fait ça s'est extrêmement
fallacieuse c'est vraiment le truc
commun à beaucoup d articles qui ont été
publiés dans des hamacs une
statisticienne c'est le fait qu' il faut
absolument réfléchir il ne peut pas se
contenter de metric donné comme ça
qu'ils sont juste déduites uniquement
des données en particulier dans la
partie réfléchir il ya plusieurs aspects
importants
le premier c'est le big picture
réfléchira le contexte global c'est
typiquement ce que j'ai fait en fin de
vidéo sur la parapsychologie la raison
pour laquelle j'ai les crédences que
j'ai pour la parapsychologie est
beaucoup plus duo big picture qui a tout
donné empirique
ensuite deuxième point important le
contexte les données sont souvent
prélevés dans un certain contexte et il
faut absolument prendre en compte ce
contexte pour bien analyser les données
les données seuls les données poète nous
nous disent pas tout il nous faut aussi
des métadonnées sur ces données c'est à
dire notamment comment ces données ont
été collectées
est ce qu'il n'ya pas eu un biais de
sélection notamment dans la manière dont
ces données ont été obtenues
attention attention aux biais de
sélection un troisième point sur
réfléchir à penser aux alternatives
on a tendance à le juger les théories de
façon isolée mais c'est très important
de réfléchir aux théories alternatives
de quelles sont vraiment les
alternatives à ce à quoi on est en train
de réfléchir
du coup c'est extrêmement important de
réfléchir à comment réfléchir autrement
que la manière de
on a l'habitude de réfléchir et enfin un
quatrième point autour de réfléchir
c'est réfléchir au moment de la
communication des résultats
voilà je suis fond d'accord avec ce
point encore une fois c'est un petit peu
tout la raison d'être de hashtag des
bâtons mieux dans la traque des bateaux
mieux il ya aussi réfléchir énormément à
comment est-ce qu'on communique telle ou
telle chose
notamment lorsqu'on communique les
sciences et les consensus scientifique
il est extrêmement important de
réfléchir longuement à comment les
communiquer parce que souvent on a
tendance à juste vouloir s'exprimer et a
pas suffisamment réfléchir à comment
s'exprimer ensuite un troisième point
soulevé par la publication et
l'importance de la transparence
et ça ça va rejoindre tous les
mouvements open s'annonce et notamment
open d'état pour savoir quelles sont les
données sur lesquelles on se se font
mais également comment est ce qu'on les
traite quelle est l'analyse de données
que l'on fait tout cela se doit être
rendue aussi transparent que possible
pour bien comprendre l'origine des
conclusions qui ont été obtenus en
particulier cette transparence est
absolument critique pour lutter contre
la malléabilité de la science qui peut
être utilisé à mauvais escient notamment
quand on a un raisonnement motivé que
celui ci soit conscient mais pire encore
lorsque celui ci est inconscient et
jouets en bois notamment à l'interview
de célia go sont daniel c'est tout chaud
puisque sa date de samedi dernier
entreprend également soulevé par la
publication c'est l'importance de l'
expertise
j'avais déjà souligné la d re fois mais
l'expertisé vraiment aidé quelque chose
qui semble émerger comme un consensus
chez sept comités de statisticiens pour
gan analyser des données il est
extrêmement important d'avoir de
l'expertisé pour bien analyser ces
données mais également une expertise
autour du contexte du big picture bref
tout ça ça revient à dire faites
attention aux préjugés calculé mois ces
préjugés de façon aussi bonne que
possible aussi réfléchi que possible et
si de trouver les fondements de ces
préjugés
faites attention à ça
réfugié et surtout questionner vos
préjugés intuitif puisque l'intuition
est souvent un très très très très
mauvais guide quand il s'agit d'analyser
été donnée vraiment méfiez vous de votre
intuition et enfin le dernier point qui
est soulevée par cette publication qui
encore une fois me fait grandement
plaisir c'est là une importance de la
modestie notamment au moment de la
communication des résultats
attention à la modestie notamment à la
modestie épistémique et faites attention
aux marqueurs de modestie épistémique ne
communiquait pas de résultats qui n'ont
pas le même niveau de crédence de la
même manière c'est important de mettre
ce genre de nuances et également
reconnaître tout ce que nous on n'a pas
réussi à prendre en compte dans notre
analyse scientifique parce que
généralement on prend très très très peu
de choses en compte dans une étude
scientifique en particulier
c'est extrêmement difficile d'avoir une
plus en compte de tout ce qui doit être
prise en compte notamment pour des
raison par exemple de puissance de
calcul est également d'expertisé
individuelles bien analyser des données
c'est avant tout le compliqué et je
pense que c'est important de le
reconnaître de savoir que tout ce que
l'on dit est fortement limité par toutes
sortes de contraintes
à commencer par les contraintes
cognitive et no limits cognitive et tous
les biais cognitifs de l'humain que l'on
connaît si bien
malheureusement je sais que la vidéo
précédente c'était pas la vidéo la plus
fun à regarder c'était pas plus
explicative pas beaucoup d'explications
c'était juste beaucoup de citations
ça peut paraître vraiment argument
d'autorité et c'est un argument
d'autorité et d'ailleurs il ya des
raisons d'hygiène de penser que le
argument d'autorité a vraiment de la
vérité et en particulier c'est vraiment
un cas où il ya énormément d'expertisé
qui parle beaucoup des gens qui ont
beaucoup moins cette expertise des
statistiques du coup c'est absolument
important de prendre en compte ce que
ces gens disent en particulier si j'ai
fait une vidéo un peu chiante où je vous
ai lu énormément de citation si pour
vraiment vous mettre dans l'ambiance de
ce que ces gens disent de façon du
général et à quel point ce qu'ils disent
est très divergents de ce que beaucoup
de vulgarisateur de scientifiques et de
journalistes disent malheureusement des
sciences il est temps de vraiment
davantage réfléchir à comment réfléchir
j'espère que j'avais un message vidéo la
pente va continuer à manipuler ce
curseur de turing pour s'habituer à
raisonner de manière by then en tout cas
lorsqu'il n'ya que deux théories à
considérer et notamment quand on bouge
est ce fameux
curseur de turing si vous avez aimez
cette vidéo pensez à le lac et à
l'augmenter à le parier qu'on sait les
abonnés pourront épisode merci aux tipa
power dont et j'espère que vous serez là
la prochaine fois
donc ça réduit énormément le temps de
traitement et comme en plus on recherche
plusieurs mots en particulier en
l'occurrence vont chercher ma terre des
riches tu as et les leaders ça permet de
faire des hypothèses qui sont de plus en
plus précises et d'avoir très très
rapidement des résultats ce qui fait
qu'on arrive à un stade où on peut
décrypter le code enigma en 20 minutes
donc on est passé de 5 milliards
d'années à 20 minutes c'est beau